if the Republicans if this group really
believes that this law is going to
bankrupt the country if they really
believe what they're saying you know
this is going to bankrupt the country
that this is an overreach of government
and it's unconstitutional even though
the Supreme Court said it then shouldn't
we maybe give them a little credit for
standing up where they believe in I'm
totally playing devil's advocate cuz
it's obviously not what I believe but if
that's what they believe do they deserve
any credit for that no I mean I mean if
you go into you have to follow you
you're you you're a product of the
environment you you're a politician you
know how this whole thing works there's
plenty of things that we don't like I
think President Obama came up with this
analogy he said no we want background
checks for guns we've been fighting for
it we still haven't gotten it there's
still a lot of Americans who are
hell-bent on shooting each other for no
reason and actually people who don't
need to have that these guns in their
hands to concede it to other people nice
it should i because this isn't what I
want frog in our government our laws now
hold up things that are actually
responsible and are necessary for us to
do to get this other part of the law
that I want because there's a second of
population that is dying for it are not
dying for what others are just really
dying to catch your patience now can't
get in yeah they're not letting them in
anymore they lock the door there's a
certain kind of dexter missing
chromosome kind of human that's okay
with that yeah and there's a bunch of
them yeah but and the one think the last
thing they want is that part exposed
oops yeah that part's out now I think
the walls are closing in on that kind of
person because it was a party set up for
a kind of person the kind of person that
knows of whatever kind of mean crap is
going on inside me I don't have to
change a thing I got a welcoming carpet
for the one places you're the guy we're
looking for do you think that's just
like you you that's based on
understanding of what's going on or you
think it's because we're pulling on
heartstrings that's all politicians that
right which is why we had stuff like the
National Zoo tweeted oh we can have the
Panda caminito right about the panacea
these kids can't get cancer treatment
literally and like the Panda cam holy
cow that's leading the research right so
final thought on this uh this is proof
to me more than anything
that I hate to be that guy but we need a
third party in this country we need
somebody between uh you know these
nutjobs on the right and then they keep
dragging the left more to the center I
mean it just seems crazy but is there
any chance is there any chance for it
remember where the compasses remember
the compass need a lot of go because
that gets moved wherever someone with
the most amount of power to put the rudd
the middle way over to the right and
you've got this little sliver left on
the end of the bathroom counter she took
it over with makeup that's in the middle
yeah and the remembering it's about
others and so they're trying to get into
everyone's head forget about others
you're on your own and the kind of
thinking I think is up for review across
the board because they made a mistake
they started screwing a lot of them too
and they're waking up I was like they
didn't do everything in the right order
right and and their own believers are
really a deep denial but they're
starting a question once you take my
supplies away and they're taking their
supplies away too does it change the
makeup of Americans for us to do that
though because Americans are so
competitive were of course our first
choice here is we're number one we're
the bestest we're the most exceptional
all these things so then that's to our
macro but then within our own country we
have our sports teams River collegiate
teams we have our schools we want to
just for pride themselves so now
everything we have those factions were
broken down so everything is a
competition so how many people enough to
garner this third party are going to
default from the Republic of our default
from the Democratic Party and say well
I'm the morning with those loyal two
teams I've been loaded two for my entire
life my grandfather Democrat all this
stuff how do we do that on a large
enough scale is the hard school I think
that's a perfect finish on that and to
that point you know for all these people
on the right that think America is so
great an America can be a great country
well then maybe giving healthcare to
everybody will actually work if we're as
great as we keep saying
hey guys the Reuben report is brought to
you by Cooper calm they've got 75
percent off dog and cat choose toys
accessories home goods and more use code
RR for twenty percent off your next
purchase the link is right down there